hello good afternoon we start with
breaking news and the prime minister has
traveled to kiev for a face-to-face
meeting with ukraine's president
ukrainian embassy in london shared this
image of the meeting between boris
johnson and vladimir zelinski
it comes after ukraine demanded a global
response to the attack on a train
station in kramatosk which killed more
than 50 civilians
what onion street called mr johnson's
visit a show of solidarity
with the ukrainian people and said the
leaders would discuss the uk's long-term
support for the country including
financial and military aid
well in a moment we'll be speaking to
our political correspondents rob powell
in westminster but first sky security
and defense editor deborah haynes is
near the presidential palace in kiev and
deborah what signal is this sending to
vlad vladimir putin at the
moment well it's a strong signal that
ukraine has
uh you know strong and powerful backers
the fact that the prime minister uh felt
that he could come here to keeve um more
than six weeks after russia's invasion
began an invasion that was meant to
topple the government of vladimir
zelensky within four days according to
western officials just shows how how
badly really it's gone in terms of
russia's plans and the fact that the
british prime minister has the
confidence to come here and he's not the
only leader um it's uh you know
no one's going to forget the fact that
the eu's uh commission president came
here yesterday there have been a whole
line of not a line there's been a small
trickle of leaders who've been willing
to take the risk of coming here to keeve
and the city here um has been
pretty much transformed over the last
few days only just over a week ago there
were heavy bombardments heavy fighting
going on in towns and villages around
the north and the northwest of the
capital which meant that this capital
really did feel
pretty close to the front line but it's
a lot calmer
at the moment and so that's probably why
you're seeing this sudden um surge or a
certain sort of movement of leaders
coming and clearly the prime minister
wanting to make sure that as other world
leaders take the risk to come here that
he as someone who has been so um out in
the front in terms of wanting to lead
the westerns the west's response to
russia's war in ukraine that he comes
here um he has that face time with
president zavinsky the palace actually
is just you can't see it from where i am
because there's checkpoints all around
but it's just beyond the buildings
behind me and we understand that the
meeting is ongoing he's had um a
face-to-face with uh the ukrainian
president it's then going to broaden out
into a larger bilateral discussion items
on the agenda of course first and
foremost is going to be ukraine's need
for weapons the the uk has been very
quick to supply ukraine with with lethal
aid from weeks before the conflict began
you'll remember those shipments of
anti-tank and law missiles and that's
been something that the uk has continued
to do and to ramp up and only yesterday
they announced another 100 million
pounds worth of aid and also saying
they're going to be bringing in mastiff
armored patrol vehicles their vehicles
with added protection a v-shaped hull to
protect from land mines
that will be used to help the ukrainian
military as they're moving around
against russian forces they're not
fighting vehicles they're not like tanks
for example but clearly lots on the
agenda and a strong signal like i said
to vladimir putin that ukraine has
allies that are not only willing to
speak out in support of the ukrainian
president but are also willing to
actually come here on the ground and see
him in person
you